So. Oh. Jobs. We rise. Ok. Ok. Mine's joshua masson and. I first came to nimbin.
When i was about two years old i came out with my parents from england and. We arrived in western australia.
And travelled right the way across the country. My parents were basically. Searching for an alternative lifestyle.
What they'd experienced when they were my age. In and and. They ended up in nimbin. And.
I was sort of directed out to the. Kamin there. And we ended up staying in the area for about ten years.
What do you know these days. Well the earliest thing i remember.
Was intolerable falls when we were living in this kind of.
Well i suppose you could call it a house it was a wooden platform.
With a big old army tent and a sort of light construction over the top of it
and struggling to get it built in the wet season. You know. Ticks and rain and all the rest of it.
And i just remember having complete freedom to sort of swim in the creek and run around there and.
You know there are a lot of other young kids my age. Sort of. Just learning to. Adventure around.
The whole place and it was fantastic i disremember running around you know in the sun on tumble.
Is not really what you want. I suppose. I would. I would have swapped. A little bit of.
The actual security of knowing that you have a completely secure home.
Because we did move around quite a bit and a lot of the drawings that were living in were pretty kind of makeshift.
From time to time. But then again. You know. There are a lot of sort of.
Advantages that come along with that as well because you know.
I always felt that i was part of a larger community and stuff like that.
And i definitely wouldn't have swapped any of them. So. You do so. How did you realize. You know. Well it was.
I suppose i felt like i was part of a larger community because we were also sort of. Involved in the same things like.
My family and all of the other families and people there were all sort of hen building their houses.
And all facing the problems of. All you know.
Of food and community living and stuff like that together and so like our saw adults.
Interacting in a different way to what you see them in mainstream society and.
That was reflected in the children as well that we sort of stayed together. As a larger group. A lot more and.
Sort of did a lot more. Of sort of daily activities together and.
This was my experience of it was jest as feeling that. All of the adults around me were a part of my family and.
You know even faces that i only just recognized i knew that i could trust because of the way that i'd seen them.
Living around me. And the same with all the children and i found it very easy to make.
And play with a lot of different children because i knew that we were all just part of this sort of big farm together.
So i was a different. Well. Well.
My education in was interesting because i spent some time in the alternative schools there. But then.
I also spent most of my primary school years at the straight school.
As it was called which was like the newman central school and.
It was at a time when children from the alternative families and the hippie settlers around the place.
Were starting to go to the. Sort of central school. And those starting to actually be interaction between.
The hippie kids and the straight kids and.
You can imagine it was quite a kind of intense sort of thing that was going on within the classrooms because there's a
lot of contention between them. Which i suppose was just a reflection of the tension in the whole community.
But that tension between us. Sort of. Dissipated. We actually got our acts together.
Over the years that i was in primary school. And it was a really interesting thing because i remember at like.
You know in years one and two and three. Feeling very sort of threatened and intimidated by the. Straight kids and.
Very separate from them. And then over the years.
And actually everything became a lot more relaxed and a lot more positive and.
By the end of that time there was actually a real lot of positive stuff happening. And.
It was funny because i didn't see as much of that. In the adult community as i did. Among the kids. And so you know.
It was i suppose that was a kind of a special thing that was going on in those laws of the vision. Was that of.
What we hear is a difference. Well all of the straight kids felt as though the hippie children in their school.
Were sort of dirty and. Weren't as sort of. Refined as.
Them and didn't have a christian upbringing was a very important part of it and.
Also kind of felt that their parents and. That they as well.
Were an intrusion into the kind of routine and the pattern that had been set up in that area.
And i suppose in a way that's rightly so because we are playing in what used to be their playgrounds
and their older brothers playgrounds and stuff like that but.
I suppose as the years went by and they realized that we could be just as much fun. And just as creative.
And just as kind of. Into sport and into all those things that they are into. Or that started to break away.
And i remember sort of. In my year in particular.
Every time we all went on an excursion together all did something that brought us together. All of that stuff.
Started to break down. And i suppose. You know. It did break down a lot faster. Among us than i did among the adults.
And you know. We would have parties and i remember having parties myself.
Where straight kids would come over and they would look different and speak differently and all that kind of stuff.
And they would kind of tentatively walk into our house and see all of the sort of hippie ornaments
and stuff like that around the place. And just be absolutely fascinated that they were.
We are allowed to go inside that.
When their parents were so hesitant about having anything to do with that part of the community and. You know.
They were actually quite proud of themselves that they were able to go and you know participate without us
and to let us into their lives as well because you know it was something that their parents just weren't able to do
and i mean i go to meetings now. And i'm nineteen years old and. I see all of the faces of those straight kids parents.
And it's still just a wall of resistance you know. And i remember. Sort of. Ten years ago.
Breaking through that wall with all those kids and having a great time with them. But now. You know.
It's just there are some things in that community. That will never change you know. Is there anything. You know.
My roots. To. I suppose. Among the adults the thing that i remember. Is walking up see.
We lived in a house just behind. Craft gallery in town there for quite a long time. We had the house for ten years and.
I remember walking up at night time and.
Just saying the kind of things that were going on in the streets there and a lot of them i didn't really understand.
But i could actually say. The mechanism between the straits and the hippies at work. And you know i would say.
A bunch of really aggressive kind of. You know people.
Run across from the rainbow cafe and punch in the windows of the pub. And then run away.
And all of this try to come running out of the pub. You know around closing time.
And fight with these people in the straight muscle that happening a lot. And you know. It was a kind of.
Two sides of the street. Type of thing going on for quite a while and i just remember. You know.
Hearing a lot of complaints about the way the straights lived in the town.
From from the alternative people that the noise from the pub. And the alcohol and all that kind of stuff and.
You know those kind of criticisms were just as strong as the criticisms from straight people. About you know.
Smoking grass in the straight and stuff like that as well. And so as far as you know.
You asked me about criticisms and straight away i am talking about the drug issue there and.
You know since we were everything leads to a dozen or so. This is the absolutely. Because you know. Like i am.
There was a lot of hypocrisy in terms of those two sides of the community criticizing each other because you've got all
of you know. All of these strikes in town at night.
Getting really really drunk in the pub and playing a lot of really loud music.
And getting aggressive and violent and tearing up and down in their cars and that type of thing. And then.
Their wives and their families.
Criticizing the alternative community for smoking drugs in the straight and for that disrupting their community.
And yet the community. We're talking about. You know it had a very sort of destructive face to it as well.
And i remember. You know on the straight kids. There was you know a lot of kind of guns and.
A lot of violence and a lot of sort of stories about domestic violence and stuff like that
and it was all very scary to me. Just the same way that. Among the straight families.
You know the whole idea of kind of smoking dope in your family and. And sort of. You know people hanging around naked.
On your community. Must have been very scary to them. So what was of these images. What was your thesis. Where. Well.
The whole thing about where lighting to other adults. In a similar way to how you do with your parents and.
You know sort of feeling that. That feeling of trust and feeling comfortable around a whole community of people.
And spending a lot of time. Of family situations at other people's places and stuff like that and.
Also feeling as though.
Not just your house is the safe place in the world but like the whole community is somewhere where you belong.
And that. You know you can kind of wonder among all those different people and still feel at home.
And i think that was the main. Thing because i noticed. You know.
Among the straight kids that they had a very kind of territorial thing about their mom and their dad.
And their family and. I sort of just really never felt there was absolutely because i mean you know.
My parents still played just as powerful a role in my life because this is there was also this whole sort of added
security of knowing that you know. You were a part of this kind of.
Maining full thing going on all around you and all those people celebrated together and work together
and all that kind of stuff and you know. Just that. That feeling of assurance was.
That was what i feel surrounded by my whole childhood. You know growing up in the. I mean. Looking to the. You know.
I think. I learned a lot about being open minded to people's points of view and being.
Exception of people's limitations and stuff like that and i think i learned about.
Sort of listening to people and being compassionate. To people's kind of.
Predicament or the people situation and so rather than. Always having a kind of.
You know motivated sort of point of view about things where you've got something to prove
or you've made a decision how you feel about things.
To actually sort of let things flow a bit more and to to see situations change and come and go.
And to be a bit more accepting of that kind of thing. And i don't know.
You know how much it's actually rubbed off politically or anything like that but i would say that you know.
Just in terms of kind of social situations and stuff like that. I think a little bit more easygoing. About.
You know about that type of thing. It's hard to actually explain.
You know the way that those values affect your behavior now. Because you know. It's pretty much you. Visible to me.
And i don't feel. I don't feel different. To all of the.
You know people in mainstream society that i'm relating to now. But sometimes i feel as though i'm a little bit ready.
More ready to be open minded and to graph situations for they are.
Than people who have got a whole load of kind of preconceived ideas that they've been taught in a very linear way from
their family and their parents. So we're well. They weren't the only the only sort of. Finding situations.
That i can remember were sort of up in town. Late at night.
When you know there was sort of violence going on around me and. I felt really kind of afraid.
And i remember sometimes. Sort of out. At the bush holes when they'd have big dances and bands out there.
And sometimes those kind of situations would get ugly.
And i would suddenly feel completely alienated from the whole thing. And that could be very frightening sometimes.
And i suppose. Like living there has also been conducive to me. Kind of. You know.
Trying different drugs and stuff like that which. You know. I probably.
It's not that i regret doing it assists that i realize now that there's actually.
You know no need to go as far into that as a lot of people do. And so i suppose you know. I didn't.
I didn't need that kind of thing. But then there are a lot of other people who have those kind of.
You know who have other reference points. You know.
Forced upon them as well like you know all those people who get into driving fast cars around.
People who get into just hanging out at the beijing doing nothing else you know.
That's just the thing that young people do together. And it doesn't.
In the end it doesn't matter whether it's one or the other. You know so.
No i don't think there are any downsides at all. Whatever the phrase. You know. You are suppose.
That makes your original. You know a bit more clear. For me. There were less downsides in growing up in that community.
Because we also maintained a lot of ties with people outside.
And i was aware of the value of a lot of things that were going on in mainstream society
and i was aware that i was going to participate. And although i was growing up in this nice kind of.
Supportive community. That i had a role to play in mainstream society as well and that.
You know i needed to be able to communicate. And i needed to be able to be sort of. Well presented.
And confident and straightforward. And all that type of thing. And so you know.
I managed to learn a bit about open mindedness and. Letting go and stuff like that by living there. But then.
Also keep it together enough to go back and do something that i consider to be worthwhile.
You know participating with everyone. Whereas a lot of people who. You know grew up as hippies out there.
Became very resentful about a lot of things in mainstream society. That made them very kind of afraid to participate.
And so they became really kind of afraid of the way the government works and afraid of the way that the system works.
And afraid of a lot of things that people do you know. On a large scale.
Because you know they weren't used to all those mechanisms.
And i weren't open minded to it and i've been taught that all of that was really bad.
And that's why their parents ran away from it. And so a lot of those people have really. You know.
Formed by the wayside and. Found very little to turn to other than sort of. You know. Drugs and kind of.
You know very kind of. How would you say. Close knit afraid little groups that they hide in.
And you see a lot of those people in the streets. Yes. You know. You do. Yes yes. Well. It's a very important industry.
They're sort of. You know a lot of people pushing hero and stuff like that through this area. Who can't. You know.
Realize that it's a lot.
It can be a lot more lucrative than working just in sydney and stuff like that
and they come up here with the intention of making a lot of money and. Often supporting a habit as well and. You know.
It ties in perfectly with the with the marijuana industry that exists here. And you know. All the people who do it.
You know. Basically really bad greedy people. And into people off. And you see it going on all the time down there.
And you know. It's fine. It doesn't bother me at all because you know.
The only people injuring people that are gullible enough to go and pay a lot of money for marijuana instead of crying.
Themselves and. You know. So it's one. It's just another one of those industries just like fast food or. You know.
Cheap cars or whatever. So you know. It doesn't. Yeah. As far as i'm concerned. You know the drug situation.
In the streets of nimbin doesn't actually need defending. Because the people who are peddling the drugs.
You know just sort of. Doing their own evil thing. And you know anyone who chooses to participate. You know.
Enters at their own risk.
And the people who are kind of falling for and buying dope to support that whole sort of system.
You know just kind of following their own indulgent pursuits and that's fine if they want to pay money for it then.
You know that's their problem and.
I suppose the unfortunate thing about it is kind of gullible people who come to him
and i don't know what they're looking for. And i find grass. And i get smashed and sit in the main street. You know.
Looking dazed and confused and. You just have to realise that those people who form by the wayside.
And i say choice to be stationary and. Indolent and.
You know to not participate in in their society or not to take advantage of what they can do. And you know.
People choose to do that in lots of ways. And you know.
Sitting around in nimbin getting smashed is just as repetitive as. Working in a steel factory or.
You know doing anything else which is kind of. Mind numbingly boring.
Well you talk to you your friends of your peers who is now. In the news. So you know this story. Sure yeah. You know.
Among people who've grown up the way that i have. They're living on communes and stuff like that.
But still actually getting an education and still realizing that you know.
There's a whole world of things to do out there. A lot of them. Like me. You know. Have sort of. Been down in sydney.
And i'm going back there and stuff like that. But then there's another group of people.
Who have sort of stayed out there and actually made a success.
Out of living in the way that their parents who established and.
I think that's a really really positive thing because you know you can actually create a really good life for yourself
out there if you choose to do that and if you feel comfortable staying in that area. And so for example.
And it's funny it's mainly people who know me to stand again now i can. And so.
Among that group of people who've grown up the way i have. And i've chosen to stay out there and to and to.
You know keep living in that area. A lot of them of kind of become involved in.
Alternative employment and self employment and. A few people come to mind like a musician i know who.
You know it could be just as successful playing in bands in sydney or up here.
And chooses to keep living on the coming. That his dad. You know was part of setting up and. Is now kind of you know.
Recording music out there and playing gigs in town and doing all. All that kind of thing.
And that really works for him. And i think that's fantastic.
And also i know a girl my age who sort of designs clothes and makes her own clothes
and sells in the markets around here and stuff like that and. She's just had a child.
Up at the commune that ice live on paradise valley.
And you know has a really nice kind of existence up there with her boyfriend. In an old house and i saw the.
People that lived in that house before. And now she's living there with a bunch of people.
You know who i knew when we were all young together.
And you know i think it's fantastic that they've chosen to stay around
and make the best of what their parents who established there. And. I suppose. You know.
It would be very hard to actually to actually say. The difference between those pay for. And the people who have.
You know kind of. How do you say. Where that whole thing is collapsed. It's a bit hard to explain.
This is this is this you know rose in this you know i wouldn't say that people my age.
Choosing to stay in this area and. Make a go of it would be the actual next chapter. Because a lot more.
Of the people who who stay around. End up finding themselves quite trapped. And quite clean of. You know.
Productive in that situation and. I suppose. There are only a few of them who've really kind of. You know.
Settled in and wanted to stay there. I'd say the next kind of.
Stage in the progress of the whole thing will be a new type of people coming to that area.
And there will be alternative settlers in the true sense of the word just like my parents' generation were.
But they'll be choosing that. Those alternatives for different kind of reasons.
Nobody realizing that they can still participate in mainstream society.
And still have jobs and still do all that type of thing.
But they don't actually have to live in the middle of the city in order to do it.
And that they can also integrate that into having a more kind of down to earth lifestyle and.
You know you see that kind of thing happening in this area quite a lot.
Where there are people who've been educated and gone to university and become sort of a the doctors or. You know.
Any kind of professions like that and then chosen to go and practice. Or do their thing. You know.
In an area where they can also live on the land.
And have a really useful comfortable life like that and i suppose you know. You could be kind of. Critical of that.
Because you know a lot of people say. All those people belong in the city and that's where they should stay.
But i don't necessarily agree with that i think if you are a writer or you know a doctor or. You know.
A schoolteacher or any of those kind of professions and you want to live on the land is a perfect place to go
and do it. You know. And you can. You know. Have a small block of land. Like the. You know. Perma culture.
Plots that are coming out now and stuff like that. You could have a small part of land. And just get on with it and.
You know and live your life the way you want to in terms of that and because there's so much. You know communication.
Sort of technology becoming available free to stay integrated with the rest of society. You know.
I think we'll see a lot more of them. So what you have for the area for me. Well i heard. The process. That.
That is happening now. Continues to happen. Which is like.
People realizing what are the good parts and what are the bad parts. Out of the alternative. That they've created.
And actually you know starting to to look at it all in the positive sense of creating
and maintaining something that's really going to work. Not just something that will help them to survive.
Running away from everything else. You know. Because a lot of people really do you just run for shelter.
From a society that was running off the rails you know. And now. They've done their. It's.
It's time to start maintaining the good part of it and you know just like in a garden. Making.
The good parts of it grow and getting rid of the stuff that you don't need. And what you do you think of it.
Well we lived. You know. In the main part of town for about ten years. And so i've had plenty of that now.
But you know. If i.
You know if i wanted to settle down and kind of live in a family situation
or in a community situation i would definitely choose this area. And whether it was kind of.
In the actual nimbin valley or in the surrounding commune. You know. Just in the general area like you know.
Bangalow way over ever. You know. I know that i'll always be. Have ties with this area. Because you know.
The land feels good to me here. But i definitely want to go and. You know.
Shake it up a little bit in the city first and travel around the world and all those kind of things you know.
And make the kind of people that would have never even conceived of anything like nimbin because there's a whole world.
Of fascinating people out there who are doing totally different things to that. You know.
And it's not as though there's just sort of sydney and melbourne. And then the alternative to that is you know.
Living up on a community this sort of. Whole other strat as a society that. You know that i want to get into as well.
So that's very good. I think because i can tell a story that makes.
All of the positive things that is here about as communities look bad. And i came. All right. Most of the people.
When i was really young about four or five years old all the people living out untouchable were sort of.
You know pretty formed kind of hippies and. You know we're all pretty much in the same situation of.
You know building our own houses and growing a little grass and selling and stuff like that and i one year.
I'm sure you'll hear a few stories about this was a big bust out of town a bow. And a lot of people.
Up for and it was a protest about the way the old town. That these people ended up doing some time anyway. And.
I remember we were living in the garden house. And.
That's right down in the bottom of the valley where the road comes up and ends and.
That's where everyone sort of goes into a tunnel from there. So you know one noise.
We heard this kind of sound from while. On the hill.
And it was a truckload of all of these people who'd been in prison for a couple of weeks or whatever.
Now coming back into the coal mine. And. They were really really drunk.
And they went to kind of people that drank a lot because as i said they were used to just growing
and smoking grass instead. And now old is absolutely. Out of their heads. And i came tearing back through the valley.
And parked the truck. And came stumbling through the whole area screaming and banging on doors.
Making a hole of noise and. The whole place was just you know. Terrified of what they were doing and.
I don't know how it ended up. Because the last thing i mean i was hiding under my pillow.
At the noise of these drunken he's stumbling through their commune in you know in victory that i've been let out.
And i got up the next morning. And wondered out into the yard. And the whole yard was kind of.
Littered with these white patches that they had left it was sort of stumbling through the hole in a live rail lawn and.
I mean i was the supposed because i was used to them being such kind of peaceful people
but to say them on the rampage like that is kind of for all you know. All these hippies must have a bit of.
You know a stright in them. As a horse try to having a bit of hip. In them as well as us who was there.
She was on and they didn't have wild and subtle actually. You know. And i didn't. All the hippie kids.
And you had you know just names like white house.
And i suppose there were some pretty wild adventures at school but it's not really the kind of things i can describe.
I think. In primary school. All of the hippie kids kind of picked up on. The strike retain quite fast because you know.
We had the school social scene and we had kind of.
You know the youth group and stuff like that and hippie kids and straight kids all treated that exactly the same way
and we you know. We all knew how much fun it was to get dressed up and get into music.
And you know do all that type of thing and so there was you know. It was no big deal there toll.
And if you give me a minute i'll be ever think of a funny story for. I also remember. A lot of kind of.
Parties and things like that to my parents took me to when i was young and.
Especially around the time of the ninety three festival which was the. Ten years after a festival. Remember seeing.
Kind of that type of. Parties that they used to set up in the holes that they like there was the blue north pole.
Which was famous for big sort of end of year parties and things like that and. They had a lot of mosque parties.
And a lot of that type of thing. And at each one of these parties there were certain things that were guaranteed.
Now you always have a whole lot of people with really long trade locks kind of standing around playing percussion.
You know. In the main hole. And a lot of people jumping around that and a lot of kids running around. And then.
Behind that there was always some kind of kitchen where someone would have set up a whole lot of really bizarre food
and food supreme but. Then you and there'd be really stoned people. Ating just. Aging this stuff.
And behind that if you eat.
When you've got the back door of these holes which i mean just like a big patch of grass out there.
And it always be a bonfire. And these people with really kind of natty dreadlocks sitting really in close to the fire.
And just sort of staring into the fire and tripping off their heads and it would just go on and on and on
and people just kind of circulate and you guy and sit by the fire frying get warm and then you going
and ate some of this food. And you go and listen to the music for a while and you just keep going. You know. Oh mine.
And i used to make these amazing kind of brews. Of. With magic mushrooms like a child tape with magic mushrooms in it.
And some people would just be you know. Drinking the stuff. By the later and.
Also some pretty incredible things i suppose
and i don't really saying that bizarre to me because i've seen those people doing that for years.
And it seems like a natural way to celebrate to me but if you went there for the first time.
You really be amazed at the kind of stuff ace to do remember the ninety three festival. Seeing a similar kind of thing.
I mean they were all of the normal type of. Pursuits like. You know. Is this rain going to ruin you. For me.
They're all the. Sort of normal festival things to do you know.
And the music and the sweat lodge and on top of things and running around in the fields. And then.
I remember seeing a great trip a festival. Who are all sitting around in this massive kind of circle.
Holding hands and. Staring up at the sky and sort of chanting these really.
Is really we had chance remember watching it. And actually trying to sort out what they're doing.
And i wish they just gave up and walked away because i can. I can understand.
You know what they're actually going for its whole. Well.
I suppose the funniest things that i used to say where the kind of things that people would get up to
when they were stoned. In the actual straits. As a child. I didn't have any problem with kind of.
Watching quite closely the type of things though doing. Money actually being offended by and.
Just sort of checking them out and i remember. You know they're the kind of really derelict hippies who you know.
Don't change their clothes for wakes and stuff like that and i would get really really drunk or.
All smashed in the street in this kind of seat there. Either a the begging or.
Or trying to irritate people as they walk past and i say. I swear to watch of ours and just sort of.
You know try and work it out without coming from. I remember this one guy who's a famous character.